hello my name is a baton over
the number of wider you which is a
company that does valorisation
algorithms it's Podesta specialized also
in a video analysis I have to the member
of companies that are here today
Jonathan and burner and we will be
splitting the talk in free part so it's
an introduction to action recognition in
Python so we will review it's quite an
ambitious program to do in 10 in 1 hour
and 20 minutes because while action
recognition you have to go to understand
how to read the video how are you going
to get some meaningful features
understand what these features means and
this discuss also our why it's
interesting to this in Python so to
start this look I will give you an
overview of what we what we want to
achieve during this tutorial it's an
interactive tutorial we welcome to ask
questions that anything you use it's not
a lecture is something that we have to
really tutorial so I expect you to
notice that if you have any question but
what we're doing and after as I said
there would be a first part that we be
related to video processing how do we
open a video in Python already see it
about our believing that with numpy
there's a certain part that go inside of
the machine learning details inside the
video processing details of the pipeline
that we will be implemented implementing
to cleaners actions and then we put all
that together and make it work so the
first step is of course for you to ever
an environment ready I know that you
have been asked to install either and I
contain your computer is actually what
Kerry account we really expect that you
have this you have to know that we will
be using a pen cd2 and opencv to is not
label on all anacondas to an all and i
canna platforms it's only available on
linux platform otherwise you may have to
install opencv to yourself or to connect
to what Carrie to do the part of the
tutorials that require opencv to you
have the URL of the repositories that
contain the source code so I really
invite you to copy it into and to
download the content of this tutorial
meanwhile I will be doing the blood and
extending bit more dot who we are as I
mentioned we are startup right now right
now and we help compare academics to
democratize the best categorize them so
what we do is that we allow people that
have innovative IDs to put the ideas on
the cloud so that they can be accessed
by people that need them and that don't
have the missile unnecessary the
knowledge to implement such techniques
are and that require basically to be
connected with academics to solve to
solve solve the problems that they have
and we specialized in image analysis we
also run a consultancy to where we try
to solve the problem that our customers
have image analysis and we recently
released an application for valentine
day that was detecting kiss kisses
people kissing and giving them function
and basically the toke sites that use
the tools that you have today will be
giving you some elements of the that we
use behind behind this application also
show you all if you hear you all know
about Python and your shoes that python
is great but i think when we do a talk
that's about computer vision and python
actually lots of people in image
processing and computer visions they
come from from that lab and it's
probably a good thing to remind why
actually it's a good idea to do to the
computer vision in Python or and pass a
meth lab but it could be C and C++ and
Fortran men and and there was initially
society that to get to be the best we
need to get some best performances and
the only way to get that was to use
difficult language like assembly
language directly and not to do anything
with a level languages and I think what
happens now with python is demonstrating
the opposite having a language that
multi-party min which you can write the
way that you like
where you have reflections but you can
actually analyze the other card is
written so that you can rewrite it in
another language where you have operator
overloading so that you can use a normal
plus in between two matrices and not
called a specific function having a
large community and having something
that's used by administrator in the web
and in Sciences is actually a great
benefits for all of us it's also very
language that's quite lightweight Soviet
with it is i mean the buy cod and pet
Python interpreter is quite like goodbye
to or too many other environment and we
have a great community and in the end
the cut is very readable and fast we
have something that fast to God and to
run I hope you are already with the
download of the the data or you in
probably still processing this I know
there's a few megabytes also continue to
start to explain now what is the
pipeline we are going to implement so
what is external recognition so it's
it's a classification task where the
data sets that we have are composed of
videos and where we want to label these
videos according to some things that's
semantics we want to say okay there was
an object in that video that did this
and historically i would say one of the
first that i said that was used was
human action data sets by even left f
and it's quite simple data sets to the
air but still areas reference and you
had to classify eight actions like
running jumping saying hi and and and
well so what we find to do is to is to
make some meaning out of this out of
these images and obviously as it's some
things that's very interesting making
meaning out of data the lots of people
that that wanted to do it and for a
while so so it's as I said an ambitious
topic to want to talk about action
recognition as end to an introduction on
that so so we can't cover everything
there are
systems that recognize one type of
action like the one we've implemented
and because it's one type of action you
can actually do not include lots of
pre-owned the algorithm if you want to
boost a little bit the performance if
you're able to do so this systems
because you're talking about video when
you talk about video actually you
talking about multimedia so you're
talking about accessing not only the
images but also the sound that does a
disability to that images so you have if
you have the Sun you may have may use a
continuous speech recognition which is
another topic of research but you have
basically people that try to extract the
meaning it with a world more holistic
approach trying to combine features that
come from the Sun and from the images
you have the i would say fairly
traditional pipeline that one we will be
discussing about which are basically in
which we cut some specific features and
we use standard machine learning after
and we use information that are apparent
in terms of local features inside of the
image to class to classify the videos
and you have approached this will
actually use actually I even want to
learn the features like deep learning
and you have even less priors so as I
said we will be focusing on a very
traditional pipeline and it could be
this pipeline we could see it everywhere
in natural language processing in audio
segmentation you find it very often it's
very classic you have your data you want
to you know your data because there was
nothing the right format you inject some
knowledge by specifying where are the
features how are you going to reduce the
mountain folk of information that you
have and then you once you have data
that is carrying enough information in
your opinion you apply machine learning
because then traditional machine
learning techniques a person have a
chance to work in our case so that I
said our video frames you're going to
make them Sparkle as I said and we're
going to use a classification method and
more exactly bag of key points in terms
of feature and support vector machines
for the machine learning that is the
moment where we may want to start to
have access to the card
is this still someone that does not
access to the grad seems alright so as I
said the first part is about video
processing in Python video processing
implies to read videos and presently
right videos and in the open source
world the reference library is called FF
MPG unfortunately the wrapper for FF MPG
hasn't been mentioned for three years
and those that because i was a mental
note of this of this package for for 18
2010 i couldn't maintain it after and
couldn't finally new mentor knows a few
people suggested they would continue it
it hasn't been continued FF MPG as
evolved so you can't use that
lightweight viper anymore but you have a
rapper that's a very available for
opencv so if you do that computer vision
you're likely to want you to use a bit
directly we want to use a pen cv but
it's not a very good rapper if you want
to process video because you can't
access you can truly sick accurately in
the images is sufficient for scientists
that know that they have simple simple
data and want to go image after one
image after the other but if you need to
seek in the video if you need to extract
son you probably would prefer MLT which
is the media loving toolkit which is a
great package that's not very known and
that's about that has been developed by
broadcasters in order to do many
operations with their videos and it's
also the back end of many open-source
video editing software so it's quite
powerful and I really invite you to have
a look at it in all cases we are with
anaconda and and what Kerry obviously
opencv is only included in anaconda on
linux and not on mac and windows and MLT
is not part of our carry of anaconda yet
so the solution for today would be to
have that that will be to access
a small video file so i invite you to go
into the part 1 folder and you have a
small script called get at ki u dot p
why she runs at five it will just
download a sequence of jpeg files that
will be developed by pil and will allow
you to work today as using a sequence of
images obviously i invite you to use the
other libraries normally if you process
videos and i've included inside of the
observer of the of the of the source
code a folder called vio it's not viu
it's VI you know for video I Oh to avoid
any conflict and you have different
players and you can see how basically
how you can open the file and with MLT
with opencv and get the frame one by one
after you have the documentation of each
website if you want to go further but at
least you have two players of videos
that you can use to to start to do video
processing and you have a felt one
called a pill for displaying images we
have kind of the same problem of course
we have met cleft lip that's there but
matplotlib is designed for creating
figures it's not designed for rendering
videos that are 30 frame per second and
opencv as some primitive too but as I
said it's not necessarily available and
I recommend that you actually use a
library called piglet which is an opengl
smaller pengie of the library for
developing pendriel applications it
installed quite easily it requires to
opengl on your platform to work
correctly and it works on all platform
maybe not windows 64 or tested that
recently it was working on windows 32
very well but maybe there is other words
you can use QT directly something inside
of the vio folder you have element
called displays and there are objects
they all have the same interface and
they allow you to display images one by
one you can run these ones
and if you run display cutie that py
after download it epic after having
downloaded the video you should be able
to see the video of a key so I can do
that here so as you can see I'm using
anaconda and I'm inside of this folder
just I use Python pass equal dot because
I don't know pipe the way I did the
module was added that quickly and might
be necessary to do that it depends on
your on your on your environment and if
I run that you just see the video being
displayed as as fast as possible so it
just there's no time on it but you've
seen the sequence of images being
displayed as better as fast as possible
so so you should be able to run that I
would say all of you if you have QT
installed I mean if you have anaconda
which is normally the case you should be
able to access that we continue on now
but in this starts to discuss about
processing as images and we'll go
further into what we call key points and
what are interesting key points but I
think if you do video classification we
want to an action air condition we want
to find inside of the images what are
the points of interesting and so point
that I testing and image is that
generally the corners and so we can
discuss about what is the right
definition but but I would suggest that
you start with to start with a classical
are east corner detector blood composed
of as you can see free elements terms of
mathematics there is a smooth thing that
is applied to the image to remove the
grittiness and not to have corner as
well as no corners there is a gradient
that will basically detect edges and
there is this formula that should remind
you a little bit of a determinant and
basically is a is in the determinant in
the tensile space and actually allows
you to select nuts the edges but the
intersection
the ages which has a car knows if you
want to do action recognition it's not
object recognition it may be very
similar in terms of framework but to get
action recognition what's interesting is
to lick link visual features with
movements and the way to do that is to
compute the optical flow and if you have
a look at this file I the optical flow
we're not going to be implemented in
Python to that would be too long but
it's available for opencv and it's very
simple to use and you can make it
accessible for an object so you can
switch from one implementation to the
other nicely after if you want to it
should be key points and not keep on us
and you can have a look at this pipe
called custom feature if you have a look
at this file it's not finished and the
idea is that right now actually we've
got to keep on detector so we can select
an image is point that are interesting
and we want to we've got the optical
flow of the image and all this is
provided us car but if you want we can
take maybe two three minutes and wait
for you to have a look at the card as
this file called histone feature and
then I will open it in front of you and
then see if you want to complete the
little bit of that are missing in Python
about how we're going to do that feature
so as I said here we're using the
obvious cornered victim you just cut it
before it was also available in
dependency but effort it was interesting
to see it then we've got optical flow
which is just calling the opencv version
of it here and then we're going to do
some kind of key point x factor which
detects the key point okay and basically
compute some descriptive I'll by using a
look at feature at the point where they
are well as other key points so I gave
you a function that we try to patch of
the image at the specific location might
not be exactly the right shape if you
feel on the border so contacts if you
look at the card it says okay where we
create the optical fluid as I once we
get the first image and then we process
the optical probe this is the first time
it will be the same image assuming
because we don't have it we don't know
what would be the movement so we assume
everything is frozen and then we go for
concatenate the intensity the intensity
intensity image of the color in wait
with the flow which is just a d stuck in
Python so it shouldn't be too difficult
the images are the same schepens that's
easy then get the key point is just
coding the preview service detectors
that we had before and and then go
through the computer local feature at
each position i will run that example
for in front of you i will when it
remotely because because as I said
there's not open sovine and I come down
on
on windows no one liked but I can relate
from here and
so here what you see is that each H
friend I I displays the optical flow
here that has been computed by optical
flow in a pensive in the window and here
you get the position of the key points I
haven't displayed them and here you get
the the descriptor associated to each
key point in that case I just took you
look at the code you have the solution I
mean the you have the complete feature
normally the computer answer a complete
feature solutions that give you an
example of feature that is just
basically what was the optical flow in
the color at this point well that's all
for the introduction on video processing
the part 1 of the tutorial and i will
let Donna explain you how you can
implement better each step of the
pipeline ok while I set up the computer
you can go to the folder called part you
and I start looking at the code
the first step is the feature extractor
okay yeah okay so the first step with
the if you are in wakari you can go to
the console and execute the GTA digit
digit sentence this one and you have the
code well if you don't have the code I
can just explain it we go check out the
code here it was plain it let's go okay
so the first part is to extract the
feature and we have two main steps the
first one is to detect the key points
because the image half out of a pixel
but not all of them are interesting and
we have different algorithms for that
and we use the so-called spacer scale so
we have the image will reduce the size
of the image and we apply different blue
rings so we have a coupon detected that
are robust to ask a valuation and the
second step is to describe the key
points but the key points they are only
one single pixel so we need to define
the region around the key point in this
case we are explaining saved but
depending of the agony then they define
different regimes so we compute the
radiance the magnitudes and the
orientation and we put all of them in a
bag torsion we call this descriptor
vector on depending of the arguing shift
has 128 elements while should has only a
64 so we can go to the code first we
import the library TV choice to extract
the features syfy's only to get the
line' image and then pile up the plot
and compile helps us so we defined here
you can see the detector list on the
script early so we can compare them we
get the image here and we'd compete
every drop and ceviche really easy with
you just have to call this instruction
feature create and you create the
detector the descriptor the first step
is to take the key points
and with those key points and the image
you can describe them with the scripture
compute and then plug the results here
are the results and you can compare them
maybe you are thinking why the circles
are have different sizes and these
depends of the treatment of the scalar
space if they if the key point was
detected in a scale space that was very
at mon-sol they mean the image was very
reduced we have a bigger point because
we are having more information about the
area and then the line that you can see
here is the the most important
orientation of this region so you want
you can play with then check the
features tractors and detectors and
descriptors and you will see that for
example fast it's only a detector matter
that but not a descriptor while sifting
Clemens both phases if you have the code
you can try to do this example is an
exercise the emotive is just to filter
the matches because what we want is to
have two images detect key points in
both of them The Scream described them
and then match them so we can find the
same object in different images ok so
the Amalfi is going to filter the
matches and keep only those that are
interesting that are important and
dramatist is a function that I wrote
because the opencv dot-to-dot for dot
sees that is start here not hapless this
function impacted in Python so well here
it will be the exercise you want to do
it but they have the solution field is
quite you see this as i told you stretch
the key points describe them this is the
most important part here and they have
probably implemented it is too much just
keep on how did you do that you can do a
brute force so it has compared its key
point with all the key points in the
other images but this is not very
efficient or where they use is flan flan
prostitutes built hierarchical tree and
start comparing only in the same level
and they use ransack so this will be the
first step which restriction so we are
talking about the kitchen project we
will have a face for example we want to
struggle features but we have a lot of
key points so what we want is to use the
bag of war technique so we would have a
lot of point in the face we want to
cluster then so we have one
the mouth so we can compare them so how
can we cluster them there are many many
algorithms we can use connectivity bass
clef steadiness word the letter example
can means that is they wanted is
implemented opencv in the bug report
technique I mean at a distance rate
based and density that in this example
is the best one but this depends of the
properties of your data set so I can
feel another example of this the same
example if you want to play with it you
have four different clusters that you
want to obtain this is the cyber assault
and using Cummings this is only the
important code collapse their mini bags
Cummings the disabilities faster that
the normal coming and you use this code
and this is only to draw the results you
have the four clusters and this is
called the boar annoy diagram so all the
sample that life in this region will be
assigning will be assigned to this
centroid and these things very basic but
you can do really cool things for
example we have this image of her shoe
we have all the data and we want to
cluster them so we can start clustering
in the feature vector so we are testing
by similarity in the region of interest
so we will have the result so these are
similar so they are clustered together
but then we want to split them so we
want to obtain each subject in a
different cluster so we can apply for
example optics that is the intensity
based clustering so you will have all
the elements i piloted this is very good
because then you can create a graph
joining this will be an out you can join
them and you will have a representation
with a graph of the of the ship and the
next step is to classify those nodes
that we have if we are talking about the
kitchen project you will have two
classes they are kissing on day or not
so this is the main formula of the super
Beta machines well this is the airplane
this is a constant that you said that it
tells you the penalty that you want to
add to a sample that is going to be
misclassified
um we have again another demonstration
have two sets let's assume that the blue
is kissing and the green is no kissing
so the first thing we can do to separate
them in this example is to draw a
straight line but we can define a lot of
straight lines so how can we decide what
is the best well the best one is called
maximum separating hyperplane and the
key point is that it lies in between
balls maximizing the distance between
the two clusters and these are called
super Beta machines that I used to
define the line but usually in the in
the database it will have this nice set
we have a lot of noise mixture and
everything so you can use even more
complex a more complex kernels it
currently is a trick that we use the
desist we have this dimensional this
dimension and we put all of those things
in a high-grade dimension will find the
impure plane and then when we go back to
the original dimension the thing that
was on a plane comes in different shapes
more complex saves and this is an
example with poly Colonel a polynomial
kernel regular basis function and the
linear we had before again you could you
can play with this data and they have
another candle that you can use and you
can change the parameters that you want
then another internet another
interesting property is that in the
database you usually have only a few
information about a class and a lot of
information i'll be over press up leader
training with images you will have a lot
of images with people in on kissing and
only a few of them dedication so what we
can do is to give more important more
importance to those samples that are
kissing so then we can put put the paper
plane in this case we are not given
importance to those points to the screen
points so what happened is that we are
not classifiable properly but if we give
more importance to these points would
post for was the paper planes you can
classify and better and have good it's
important to to find or to estimate the
best colonel in this case is the radial
basis function
and here I have the samples another
technique if you are working with
clusters is just instead of giving only
waits at the same way to all the class
give the great depending of the distance
between the point and the centroid so
you can see that is very different here
the classification is overfitting i will
say in summer 15 and in this case is
more generalized because this point is
very far from there from the center ring
so he has very loved by you and what
we're ready for the part 3 but if you
want to play with the code which is now
the moment you can ask us if you want I
guess you were playing know whatever you
want Jonathan
because what's a flame time will should
move on to the next stage
hello hi now we're going to sort of give
you a little wet spot three now we're
talking about and in there is some code
that you can sort of take home with you
play with and we're just going to give
you a sort of basic introduction to like
the form of how you should sort of code
some of this stuff and then you can make
it as complicated as you like as you
take your home I'm just going to briefly
describe this off steps the concepts
have already been explained so I will go
into too much detail we start with our
feature detection so we take our image
get a bunch of sorry get a bunch of
features from it then we want to sort of
reduce the complexity so we do a bit of
compression using PCA so we get a bunch
of we'll get a mean and a set of
eigenvectors and then we're going to
pick a subset of the eigenvectors so
we're kind of like choosing the most
important this or quintessence features
of our data after that we'll move on to
doing clustering and then finally with
all of this information we will generate
a graphic model which is to do with that
sort of the pca projection and we're
gonna from our clustering will get
centers in that sort of describes our
bag of words and from that we'll be able
to after that stage is done we'll work
to compute new features in terms of the
pre-existing graphic model and the bag
of words such it's sort of described in
a similar basis and then we can move on
to throwing these things that
classifiers later on and this is sort of
how we do the computing features in
terms of the bag of words so for each
image we get all the features and we're
just going to stack them so we get one
big sort of matrix then we do the pc a
project to get it in the same basis as
our graphic model then we're going to
calculate the distances from these these
objects to the clusters and this isn't
exactly what we want because the
distances are obviously
be small when they're close and big when
they're far away and in fact we want a
sort of waiting a smoothing function so
that when our sort of feature is close
to our center then it's big and when
it's far away it's small so we just
invert that with a parameter we called
the discriminator it's something you can
test and see does it work well in this
application it's got to try to narrow at
that point and then because we've sort
of messed about with this waiting we
need to sort of normalize a data so we
normalize the guy so the error is one
and then we do a mean of the entire
stack so we just get one histogram which
will represent that particular image in
terms of our bag of words and we use
this thing to throw our classifier so if
you go and have a look at your your part
3 folder three fingers any gay and I'm
going to sort of talk you through the
code a bit where is it is it the other
side here we go all right part 3 so all
right there's a whole bunch of files in
here sift features are just a whole
bunch of basic functions sort of doing
the feature extraction we were doing
before loading images etc not
particularly exciting so we're going to
start on our bag of words and it will
open hopefully there we go but you see
it
alright then we just start with some
defining our class so it's a bag of
words we do some initialization so it's
either going to take a detector or
description or a path where we've saved
the previous model of this class and
then we do using the detection
descriptive stuff there's functions to
save using pickle and load so it's nice
and easy you can put this model about
where if you like and yeah how do I do
that there we go being here somewhere
okay do you know
do what sorry I don't know sorry I'm not
very good with Max
no oh yeah
sorry about this
there you go front try that one be
someone a big girl please
alright well just have to continue sorry
about that but either way you can
download the code and look at it and
I'll try to describe it in words anyway
so the important sort of function here
is our train function and this will take
a whole bunch of paths from a sort of a
training set and defines a whole bunch
of parameters K which is the number of
clusters we're going to have in our when
we do our k-means and the criteria so
this is sort of like the acceptance
criteria then the amount of times you
want to do it because we're using random
centers it just places random centers in
feature space and then we'll calculate
the distances and do that bunch of times
and then the sort of the best correlated
ones it would choose it sort of optimum
clusters so yeah we're just saving some
parameters get our detector and
descriptor then we're going to load in
our first image from the path so the fir
first path and then we're going to
iterate over all of the rest of them and
can concatenate upon that array to get
our sort of big vets deck and there's
just a little check there to make sure
it doesn't add key points if then none
because occasionally your key point
detector won't find anything so it will
return you nun and you don't want to
concatenate that to the stack because
you'll mess up everything else later
then the next stage is to do the square
root on that that's useful for PCA it
gives you a little bit of extra sort of
performance there then you do a mean on
the whole thing to get a single
histogram and then you throw that at
your pc a compute to get your mean in
your eigen vectors then you do that
stage again but in putting all of the
stuff you had before and this time
you're specifying the number of the best
ligon vectors you want back out and that
was one of the parameters you gave it
and sort of a deep thought one I used
was 96 but you can you can play with it
and optimize and sort of do some
parameter bashing to see which one's
best and if you write nice portable code
then you can just sort of take them
along with you so after that you just
return out you do UK means your last
step and
return out you mean eigen vectors and
centers and that formed will the meeting
and the eigenvectors form your sort of
PCA graphic model and their centers your
bag of words right now let's run this
wherever it is so I'm just going to use
ipython for convenience which one is it
that one got it thank you alright then
the end of the function you have our end
of the file you have a function called
demo if you run it will go and compute
you your very first bag of words and if
you are sort of have a look it's just
getting paths with a module called data
sets and that's just got some useful
functions for sort of looking through
directories and pulling out JPEGs and
stacking a big list of them and it's
also got some useful functions for doing
creating reports after you've done the
SVM and whole bunch of stuff there so
that gets you out all your puffs and
we're going to use the sword apposite
dataset pause for a sort of training
example and we just specify detector and
descriptor trainer model on the path and
we save it and just to show you it being
portable I've deleted it reloaded it
from the file and then just print out
the answer at the end which is once it's
done it should spit spit that stuff out
alright the next thing we want to show
you ever it is part three is are
actually doing the computing stuff in
terms of the bag of words and that's
this file here so are going to do a
little bit of inheritance so inherit our
bag of words
then we do our detect and compute
project which takes the key points using
your detecting compute projects it into
the basis of your graphic model and then
just has a little check stage for if it
got an invalid thing it just creates a
vector of the same size field of zeros
and you add that instead of your your
failed guy and then you'll actually
compute the future itself in terms of
the bag of words and then what we're
doing here is getting our projection
then we're doing in the distance using a
metric and this metric is specified wall
we picked Euclidean for basic ones but
you can do city block which would have
go along like square waves vertices if
you look at the documentation there's a
huge range of functions to play with so
you can sort of have a little mess about
with that and then we invert those
distances with our discriminator has
described so you can pick a different
power see that help how that kind of
works and then because if we had any
zeros in the bottom they would have
blown up to infinity so we set them back
to one then we just renormalize an
output the last stuff and then we just
save it for this demo so hopefully the
other demo is finished running by now
hopefully yeah and that's sort of the
last one so gonna run this new file
feature computer do a demo and this one
is just proving it does what it says it
does so it's going to load up the
graphic model which we generated in the
last demo then it's going to just
compute the values for a compute the
histogram for a particular file they're
now going to move on to more interesting
stuff which is the sort of the final big
stage and that's our the SVM trainer
testa chop just described
s'okay the first lecture I'm going to
talk about takes your model which we've
generated so your vision model will
you're like a words guy then take some
parameters and an ID then it generates
using our dataset generator the train
set paths the labels for them is +1 if
it's kiss minus 1 if it's not then we
generate a test set and test set labels
from these given path so it's going to
go through the pause neg positive
negative and the last things are just
specifying how much you want for each
then we will stack all of those features
for the training data so you just
compute all of those guys and have a
nice V stack at the end of it and then
we're going to initialize our cv to SVM
and then this stuff's interesting we
were talking about the parameters used
for sort of optimizing your SVM
fortunately opencv has a sort of a
really nice tool where you just define
grids of your parameters and throw it at
it and then it will go through
cyclically through all of them and work
out the best ones and sort of your your
gamma is to do with its to do with the
RBF it's sort of the size and the scope
of it and you'll see parameters which
are to do with penalizing outliers in
sort of in the system and then you give
it some training data with the labels
you give it a whole bunch of parameters
and then you say go and it runs for a
little while and then it will generate
your SVM which is contained in that
little guy there then next thing we want
to test it so we do some get our test
data and concatenate the stack for that
guy then we give it it get it to predict
all its labels and then this a bit messy
but it just computes the success rate
given sort of comparing the labels given
what the SVM throughout then we want to
save it then we want to generate a nice
little report then we're going to save
our model and the return types it would
returns the current k value so the
number of clusters for your particular
model the maximum components which
number of eigen values
and finally the success rate and the
reason why we want to do that is because
we're going to want to throw these guys
that are we've got a pram bash function
which will iterate over a whole bunch of
caves a whole bunch of ease and then
generate models using those those
parameters and they will do that for all
of them and then it will go and draw a
grid so we can actually see which
parameters were doing best and so if you
use lots of data you may want to do it
right over more than just two parameters
I mean when we're doing our project we
had a whole sweep of them during a nice
little 3d graphs etc and then the final
thing we just want to draw this sort of
grid out and we're just going to set
sort of the y YX ease I'm not gonna
explain it it draws a gruff and it will
plot them and then the lighter the color
of that particular node the better the
performance of that sort of parameter
set now running this guy here it's going
to take a little while because it's
quite if you're using wacky it will
certainly take a little while svm this
guy and then run / am bash now this will
iterate all of it generate our new
models evaluating their performance and
while it's doing that it's going to be
generating reports and putting them in
the directory with your model and
everything yeah you sort of get with you
so here's a example of one of the output
file so that it's a zeroth model it
saves the model itself then you have a
nice little report and we can have a
look little looking this one did seventy
percent here's the positives and
negatives and then after this thing has
run for a long while you'll get one of
these images out it will spit it out as
a gruff and here you can see the sort of
like the variation as i said the lighter
colors are the better performance so
they'll be sort of one hundred percent
there that might be worse and you as i
said you may want to iterate over a
whole bunch of them and check out
different parameters mess with the
discriminator and let's sort of left for
a sort of a bit of homework as you like
to go and mess about with this stuff and
you can swap out the feature vectors use
different ones and maybe you start using
some of the Harris ones that Bertrand
was are sort of doing and then not again
and so yeah that's essentially it as I
said this guy will take a little while
to run so uh oh sort of get back to
button for a minute
I don't know it is working yes well that
was all for this for this tutorial are
in terms of content think there's a lot
to be done to play with the car that we
ever we have submitted to you and sends
the tutorial and we expect it to be
interactive so we fought at easier doing
the exercise by making a break in the
presentation but all these are doing a
session where we we stay with you and we
have a look and went to ask your
question at that guess that what we will
be doing now I thank you a lot for for
your time and for your attention if you
have questions so do not hesitate to ask
us I've put the slides if you want to
access the slides on our Twitter so it's
all about why do you can you can find
the slides if you need to to sorry it's
not what i wanted to do just let that
one well it's our x value for the slides
and you can and otherwise that we here
transvaal were Christians for the next
20 minutes thank you